le transhumanisme à ses adeptes avec
l'espoir de supprimer le vieillissement
et la mort mais aussi ses limites à la
fois scientifiques et éthique la preuve
à l'instant s'il le fallait avec ce
documentaire réalisé par Thomas Licata
dès lors dans le cadre de la loi
jusqu'où les sciences et les techniques
peuvent-elles procurer l'espoir de
prolonger la vie nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débat doc avec vous tout
d'abord
Eric Gilson bienvenue à vous vous êtes
biologiste directeur de l'Institut de
recherche sur le cancer et le
vieillissement à la faculté de Nice vous
travaillez plus spécifiquement sur la
cdcence qui est un processus
physiologique qui entraîne une lente
dégradation de la fonction de la cellule
qui est à l'origine du vieillissement
des organismes on y reviendra j'imagine
dans un instant avec vous Jean-Marc
Lemaître est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes biologiste directeur
de recherche Inserm et co-directeur de
l'Institut marketing régénératrice et de
biothérapie de Montpellier votre ouvrage
s'intitule guérir la vieillesse il a été
publié aux éditions humaines sciences
c'est un titre un peu provocateur
dites-vous dans une interview publiée
dans Le Point mon ambition c'est
d'arriver à faire comprendre que la
vieillesse est probablement probablement
une maladie dites-vous dans cette
interview du point qui date de l'automne
dernier on y reviendra aussi avec vous
dans un instant Amandine Caillol est
également avec nous et bienvenue vous
êtes maîtresse de conférence en droit
privé à l'université de Caen et vous
avez codirigé avec Émilie gaillard un
rapport
transhumanisme et droit réalisé pour
l'Institut des études et de la recherche
sur le droit et là justice on va revenir
sur l'ensemble de ce documentaire vous
nous direz au passage que vous en avez
pensé de ce documentaire et du
traitement des limites du transhumanisme
puisque c'est de cela qu'il est question
dans ce film avec des réponses
scientifiques et aussi des réponses
éthiques la cryogénisation ce phénomène
semble se répandre notamment aux
États-Unis 300 personnes dans le monde
aujourd'hui auraient choisi de congeler
leur corps parfois leur cerveau on a
appris tout ça dans dans ce film en
espérant revivre dans le futur alors là
c'est très impressionnant on touche
presque à la science-fiction je voudrais
juste qu'on fasse un premier point sur
ce phénomène de cryogénisation on le
voit apparaître notamment aux États-Unis
assez fortement notamment dans cette
clinique que nous avons visité avec le
réalisateur de ce film faut-il y croire
y a-t-il des études scientifiques qui
attestent que demain si on se fait
cryogéniser on peut avoir un espoir de
revenir à la vie dans le futur
d'un point de vue
purement scientifique il y a rien qui
nous permet d'ailleurs ça a été dit très
bien dans le film des
scientifiques ça puisse être réalisable
maintenant c'est aussi vrai
qu'actuellement en laboratoire on peut
congeler des embryons et les de souris
par exemple et puis les ramener à la vie
donc par des procédures spécifiques bon
c'est des organismes beaucoup plus
simple est-ce que ça peut s'appliquer à
l'homme je crois que là il y a vraiment
un fossé de connaissances qui nous
empêche de le dire donc mon impression à
la vision du film c'est que on vend du
rêve finalement plus qu'une réalité
scientifique avérée et en vend du rêve à
des personnes fortunées puisque on
apprend dans ce film qu'il faut compter
000 dollars par exemple pour une
cryogénisation qu'en pensez-vous
alors même avec votre confrère alors
faut jamais dire jamais bien sûr en
science mais mais effectivement
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de preuve
scientifiques qui nous permettent de
dire que dans le futur on pourra
remettre à la vie des personnes qui ont
été congés maintenant on voit bien dans
ce reportage que que c'est vraiment un
espoir et c'est ce qui est vendu c'est
l'espoir c'est pas il y a rien de très
scientifique par contre on voit que
effectivement on prend des précautions
c'est à dire que avant de congeler les
gens déjà on les congèle à très haute
température ce qu'on fait un peu pour
les cellules pour les ressortir
intactes on est obligé de les congeler à
très basse température rapidement au
moins moins 190 c'est ce qui nous est
dit on peut le faire aussi pour des
embryons comme vient de le dire monsieur
Gilson et
mais au-delà quelques tissus on arrive à
le faire mais au-delà pour l'instant
aucun organisme réellement mammifère en
tout cas a pu être congelé il y a des
petits il y a des petits organismes qui
qui peuvent l'être mais mais rien de
rien de plus donc effectivement c'est
c'est vendre un espoir
qu'est-ce qui est possible de faire
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la loi
alors en France c'est interdit alors en
France c'est clairement interdit
effectivement les seules possibilités
concernant le cadavre c'est la crémation
ou l'inhumation éventuellement le don à
la du corps à la science également et de
toute façon là c'est vraiment que ça a
été clairement décidé par le Conseil
d'État on est une célèbre à faire
Martineau en 2006 un médecin qui avait
congelé sa femme et qui ensuite avait
voulu être congelés lui aussi et le
Conseil d'État a indiqué que ce n'était
pas possible d'avoir recours à la
cryogénisation congélation du corps
c'est formellement interdit en France et
on avait d'ailleurs eu aussi toujours en
2006 une question au gouvernement qui
avait été posée sur cette question on
s'était demandé enfin la question était
de savoir si on enterre le caisson de
cryogénisation est-ce que finalement ça
ne pourrait pas entrer dans inhumation
et clairement la réponse a été non ça ne
correspond pas aux modalités prévues par
la loi sachant que la réponse du
gouvernement avait insisté sur le fait
que nous l'objectif c'est aussi que les
corps disparaissent et notamment pour
des raisons salubrité publique et aussi
de place dans les
concessions funéraires ce que ne
permettrait pas justement la
cryogénisation donc en France c'est
clairement interdit pour l'instant en
tout cas alors où est-elle autorisée
alors du coup aux États-Unis on l'a
compris ensuite on commence ce
documentaire avec une entreprise suisse
alors en réalité il y a deux endroits
dans le monde où c'est interdit par
exemple dans certaines provinces du
Canada et ailleurs il y a en général pas
de d'autorisation Express il y a pas de
loi qui autorise la cryogénisation mais
on a une certaine forme de tolérance
dont de très nombreux États donc
effectivement les États-Unis la Suisse
ou l'entreprise là qui a été justement
visité dans le documentaire ainsi sur le
fait qu'ils ont eu des avis sur lesquels
pour eux en Suisse ça pourrait justement
rentrer dans le don du corps donc on
pourrait donner le don le corps à la
science ou donner le corps à des
fondations sociétés de cryogénisation
pour le faire cryogénéiser
mais en pratique des instituts
cryogénations il y en a assez peu dans
le monde depuis les années 70 on en a
deux aux États-Unis le corps que vous
avez visité dans le débat dans le
documentaire et puis le crying ensuite
il y a eu un institut en Russie Cry
russe et puis on voit par contre que
c'est quand même un rêve qui tend à se
développer puisque dans les années
dernières années on a eu un nouvel
institut en Chine un en Australie et
puis tout dernièrement en Suisse
première institut européen donc c'est un
rêve effectivement mais un rêve qui est
quand même tant à être de plus en plus
partagé par nos concitoyens alors
peut-être dernière chose peut-être un
dernier indication par rapport à tout ce
qui a été de la première partie de ce
film certains ou certaines
souhaitent voir leur cerveau uniquement
cryogénisé quel est l'intérêt
scientifique que cela pourrait avoir
dans le futur justement je pense que la
façon ça a été dit pendant le film
l'idée c'est de garder notre mémoire
notre identité finalement personnelle
notre conscience du cette façon de ce
qu'on a vécu ce qui est certainement
théorie en partie vrai c'est vrai que le
cerveau la question je me suis posé
quand j'ai regardé le film et auquel
j'ai pas de réponse mais c'est une vraie
question c'est de savoir si finalement
tout autre mémoire telle qu'on l'a telle
qu'on la conçoit notre conscience
finalement réside uniquement dans le
cerveau donc certainement grande partie
mais est-ce que uniquement dans le
cerveau je crois que c'est une question
qui reste ouverte vous avez quelque
chose à dire en plus que ce que vient de
dire votre confrère ou pas oui en fait
en regardant le film on voit on voit
bien le
refroidissement du corps le temps que ça
peut prendre etc quand on sait que que
lorsqu'on reste trois minutes en absence
d'oxygène en anoxie on a des des
séquelles irréversibles au niveau du
cerveau on peut quand même se poser la
question du fondé de de cette de cette
stratégie on va voir un extrait du
documentaire il concerne les limites de
la science et c'est Judith campizi qui
est une de vos concerts américaine qui
est bio chimiste et biologiste qui parle
on ne peut pas repousser la vie de
manière très significative avec
aujourd'hui les données scientifiques
que nous avons si je résume ce que vient
nous dire votre concert ça c'est le
constat de base aujourd'hui il y a une
limite madame calmant avait 122 ans et
en croire ce que j'ai lu issu là sur le
sujet au-delà de 115 ans entre 115 ans
et 120 ans on considère aujourd'hui que
c'est la limite où on peut repousser le
vieillissement dans l'état actuel des
connaissances des sciences est-ce que ça
c'est une base sur laquelle tout le
monde peut être à peu près d'accord du
côté des scientifiques oui je pense
qu'il faut apporter quelques nuances
d'abord dans les propos que vous avez
rapportés de Judith campizi il y a quand
même deux aspects il y a à la fois la
longévité maximale et aussi l'état de
santé la partie longévité chez la souris
c'est trois ans chez nous c'est à peu
près 120 ans le
c'est effectivement ça paraît être une
limite pour l'instant qu'on sait pas
dépassé bon je fais la souris peut-être
un petit peu plus que ce qu'a dit qu'en
physique mais pas de manière
spectaculaire
et donc l'autre question et je crois que
c'est pas ma spécialité mais je lis
beaucoup de décrits de démographes
justement qui travaillent sur ces
questions le problème c'est que les
personnes qui vivent très très longtemps
et les supercentaires comment les
appelle finit très peu finalement donc
c'est très très difficile de faire des
statistiques pour savoir si finalement
on va passer de 120 122 123 en
augmentant le nombre de 2009 c'est
encore un débat qui reste qui reste
ouvert il y a pas de peur que les
centenaires de peut-être une aubaine
pour vous chercheur vous biologiste pour
le travail sur le vieillissement c'est
un avis que vous partagez oui d'ailleurs
ça a été très bien présenté par
miroslavradman dans le documentaire
les personnes qui dépassent 100 ans
c'est souvent des personnes qui n'ont
jamais été malade ou quasiment et donc
c'est probable des gens très robustes
sur lesquels bien peut-être il y a
effectivement un certain nombre de de
marqueurs de choses très spécifiques et
qu'on peut aller rechercher et donc il y
a tout un pan de la recherche oui qui
travaille sur les centaines et super
centenaires pour essayer de voir quels
sont ces déterminants qui font que ces
personnes vivent plus longtemps que la
majorité des gens quels sont les
questions qui se posent juridiquement
quel est le cas dans lesquels officie
nos deux invités par exemple présent sur
ce plateau le cas de législatif le cadre
éthique aujourd'hui quels sont les
questions que soulève les recherches sur
le vieillissement aujourd'hui justement
on a surtout un encadrement de tout ce
qui est recherche modification génétique
en là où il y a des limites puisque dès
94 donc les premières lois bioéthiques
on a réalisé une distinction entre les
modifications génétiques qui ne sont pas
transmissibles à la descendance et qui
ne pose pas trop de problèmes on va dire
éthiquement et donc juridiquement et
puis les modifications génétiques
transmissibles au contraire à la
descendance qui là sont clairement
proscrites en France donc encore
aujourd'hui on a un principe de respect
de l'intégrité l'espèce humaine et donc
c'est modifications génétiques sur
l'embryon doivent d'une part répondre à
une finalité particulière donc soit une
finalité de pro de pronostic
prédictive ou thérapeutiques et d'autre
part ne doivent jamais être transmis à
la descendance mais ce qui est un peu
paradoxal c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire
naître des enfants génétiquement
modifiés en France c'est absolument
impossible mais comme je disais
paradoxalement pour ne pas prendre de
retard sur la recherche on autorise de
manière de plus en plus permissive de la
recherche tout de même sur l'embryon à
condition d'en suivre détruire ces
embryons qui auront été génétiquement
modifiées le cas de législatif pour la
France sont les lois bioéthiques elles
sont révisées et révisables
régulièrement c'est même ce qu'impose la
loi alors la première c'était 1994 vous
l'avez évoqué ensuite 2004 2011 et 2021
durant cette période on a vu des
évolutions
notoires dans le
le cap dans lequel sont permis les
recherches dans le domaine qui nous
intéressent aujourd'hui pour le coup
comme je le disais on a vraiment une
évolution vers une acceptabilité de plus
en plus grande donc 1994 c'est un
principe d'interdiction des recherches
sur l'embryon très clairement 2004 là on
a toujours le principe d'interdiction
mais avec des dérogations temporaires en
2011 même règle principe d'interdiction
dérogations qui deviennent pérennes et
en 2013 on a une loi qui n'est
intervenue que sur ce point là donc
c'est pas une grande loi bioéthique mais
2013 pour la recherche sur l'embryon
c'est très important puisqu'on a un
complet changement de paradigme on
renverse le principe le principe ça
devient l'autorisation si certaines
conditions sont remplies et en 2021 on
reste sur la même la même idée mais les
conditions ont été assouplies notamment
jusque là dans les conditions il fallait
une finalité médicale et désormais il y
a plus besoin d'une finalité médicale il
suffit d'augmenter les connaissances sur
la biologie humaine c'est quand même
beaucoup plus large qu'une finalité
médicale et autre en 2021 alors les
chercheurs pour mieux expliquer que moi
ce que ça change en pratique pour eux
jusque là on avait réglementé uniquement
la recherche sur l'embryon en général
qui donc se mise à autorisation et en
2021 on a dissocié une autre un autre
type de recherche recherche sur les
cellules pluripotentes donc notamment
les cellules souches embryonnage et des
cellules pluripotentes induites qui là
n'est soumis qu'à une simple déclaration
donc c'est une des recherches qui sont
beaucoup plus faciles du coup à réaliser
car elle poserait des problèmes éthiques
moindres alors dans ce cadre tel qu'il
est posé vous avez vous choisi de de
pousser les recherches dans le domaine
de la sénes j'évoquais tout à l'heure
processus physiologique qui entraîne une
lente dégradation des fonctions de la
cellule et vous entendez essayer de
stimuler le le système immunitaire pour
lutter contre contre ce phénomène
explique-nous très simplement pour tous
ceux qui nous regardent quel est quel
est votre le sens de vos recherches
aujourd'hui sur quoi vous vous pouvez
espérer travailler positivement sur le
vieillissement et le rallongement de la
vie je crois que la plupart des
laboratoires au monde incluant le mien
et celui de Jean-Marc certaines façons
aussi qui travaillent sur le
vieillissement travail sur la
compréhension d'une cause qui soit
commune à toutes les effets j'allais
dire du vieillissement incluant les
maladies qui qui sont liées la cause qui
est la mieux établie maintenant qui veut
pas dire que ce soit la seule cause et
la mieux établie c'est justement la
sénes des cellules et ça ça date de 1960
pour être très précis avant 1960 on
pensait que les cellules étaient
immortelles donc ça veut dire que si
nous nous vieillissons c'est pas à cause
d'un de nos cellules depuis 1960 et
c'est là où le film j'ai trouvé Falla
très émouvant d'une certaine façon qu'à
la fin on termine le film avec le des
flics qui est le californien qui en 1960
contrairement au dogme du moment et
découvert en fait que ces cellules
n'étaient pas immortelles étaient
mortelles donc rentré en sénescence et
donc j'ai trouvé vraiment émouvant de le
voir là dans son dans
j'allais dire dans dans son jus de
forêts de séquoia c'était c'était très
intéressant mais donc voilà donc il a
fallu attendre de 1960 jusqu'à que très
récemment pour montrer qu'effectivement
c'est l'accumulation de ces cellules
saines qui détermine en partie
finalement le vieillissement normal et
aussi les maladies qui sont favorisées
par par ce processus de vieillissement
vous êtes donc à la recherche de
comment faire avec ces cellules c'est
naissantes comment
dépatouiller et ce qui est vraiment
compliqué c'est qu'en fait ces cellules
saines sont pas si néfastes que ça et on
la coupe on répare notre peau on fait
des cellules saines de manière très
transitoire même pendant notre
embryogénèse il y a un moment où on fait
des naissances et c'est naissantes nous
protègent contre le cancer donc comment
dissocier tous ces mécanismes pour
trouver le j'allais dire la bonne
direction le bon équilibre j'allais dire
entre toutes ces fonctions des cellules
etc pour vieillir en bonne santé mais
sans faire de cancer je crois que c'est
vraiment le ce qu'on en anglais on dit
un bottenex et c'est vraiment une étape
limitante même j'allais dire une étape
conceptuellement limitant dans notre
domaine vous vous partez presque du
principe que la vieillesse est une
maladie
alors oui alors ça faut nous expliquer
alors je vais vous l'expliquer c'est
qu'en fait la recherche sur le
vieillissement comme le disait
eric
a beaucoup progressé on est en train de
comprendre comment nous vieillissons une
des étapes importantes c'est la scène
naissance mais ce n'est pas la seule on
sait que
on peut repérer comment vieillissent nos
cellules avec un certain nombre de
marques
il y a eu un consensus de différents
chercheurs qui se sont mis autour de la
table pour dire voilà si on a ces
marques là c'est que nos cellules
vieillissent et finalement
si on vieillit c'est parce que c'est le
vieillissent donc dans un cas ils vont
rentrer dans ces mécence parce que
effectivement elles sont endommagés sont
stressés et il va falloir que que
qu'elles essaient de réparer quelque
chose et puis parfois elle répare et
puis elle continue mais elle continue en
gardant des traces et quand elle garde
des traces on je dirais que nos cellules
qui sont programmées pendant le
développement et bien petit à petit il
se déprogramme et là c'est une cellule
qui vieillit donc en fait dans nos
tissus avec le temps on a deux types de
cellules les cellules c'est naissantes
ont tendance à s'accumuler et les autres
cellules qui sont pas saines mais qui
vieillissent et qui fonctionnent
beaucoup moins bien sur le principe de
d'essayer de trouver une cause commune à
aux maladies de tel le cancer maladies
dégénérative qui effectivement cause
beaucoup de décès aujourd'hui en France
là dessus il y a une espèce de consensus
scientifique aussi il y aurait une cause
commune à ce type de oui c'est le
principe même de justement
ces deux marques du vieillissement on
les retrouve dans toutes les pathologies
liées à l'âge et d'ailleurs
si on cible ces Marx c'est à dire qu'on
détruit les cellules ces naissantes et
bien on va quand même chez ces animaux
et là je vais je vais compléter un peu
ce qu'a dit Judith campizi c'est qu'on
gagne quand même entre 25 et 30 % de vie
en plus en bonne santé sur sur les
modèles animaux si on reprogramme les
cellules de ces cellules même chose donc
ça veut dire des reprogrammer des
cellules là est-ce qu'on rentre pas dans
un terrain justement éthique
problématique par exemple je voudrais
bien comprendre ce qu'on entend par
reprogrammer les cellules parce que vous
semblez avoir obtenu un certain nombre
de résultats dans ce domaine dans votre
laboratoire
reprogrammation des cellules on est sur
un terrain
là c'est une modification de somatique
on peut reprogrammer des cellules
simplement en activant un certain nombre
de gènes mais sans avoir de trace de
génie ajouté parfait c'est plus c'est
plus compréhensible comme ça oui non je
pense que le
malheureusement il y a un type de
cellules qui sait très bien reprogrammé
c'est les cellules
précancéreuses et les cellules
cancéreuses c'est exactement ce qu'elle
font et le problème alors au-delà de
cette constatation de mécanique de
mécanisme qu'on pourrait très bien
imaginer quand qu'on soit capable
finalement de de dissocier finalement
cet effet de reprogrammation cancéreuse
et de reprogrammation j'allais dire
bénéfique pourquoi pas on y est pas
encore mais pourquoi pas le problème que
ça pose c'est comment le démontrer pour
l'appliquer à l'homme une souris sa vie
trois ans d'accord elle a pas le temps
de faire un cancer ça veut dire que
toutes les études qui sont faites chez
la souris en cette limite j'allais dire
pratiquement donc
moi personnellement je serais
extrêmement méfiant de reprogrammer mes
cellules même si les sourires me
montrent qu'elles vivent sans cancer
simplement parce que c'est pas le bon
modèle c'est à dire que c'est pas le bon
modèle pour l'application l'homme c'est
un excellent modèle pour comprendre des
mécanismes mais pour l'applicabilité à
l'homme c'est pour le vieillissement
c'est extrêmement compliqué parce que
elles vivent pas longtemps elles n'ont
pas le temps de faire des cancers et en
plus elles ont ce qu'on appelle des
trajectoires de viement extrêmement
différents elle vieillissent très très
rapidement nous on vieillit de beaucoup
plus lentement même ne serait-ce que la
les périodes de reproduction le nombre
d'enfants qu'on fait ce sont des
paramètres qui rentrent en compte et on
est vraiment très loin et c'est vrai que
s'il y a un consensus dans la communauté
pour dire comme disait miroradman que on
aura la cause première et puis on va
pouvoir ralentir le vieillissement à mon
avis moi je travaille dessus donc c'est
passionnant d'un point de vue j'allais
dire de la compréhension des mécanis
biologiques à mon avis contrairement à
ce qu'on entend très souvent l'appli à
l'homme on en est très loin en tout cas
ils sont bien voir un avenir dans ce
domaine ce qui expliquerait évidemment
que les gafams s'intéressent beaucoup au
travail sur le vieillissement grâce au
Big Data c'est presque main basse sur
les données aujourd'hui personnels de
santé que font les gafams alors là aussi
en Europe il y a un certain nombre de
protection quel est le cas dans lequel
travaille les gafam aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui est autorisé ou pas chez
nous à contrario aux États-Unis pour
pour une avancée dans ce domaine et
est-ce que les gafams peuvent contribuer
positivement on veut dire sur ce travail
consacré au vieillissement là encore une
fois la réglementation est pas la même
partout effectivement puisque nous en
Europe on a le rgpd donc le règlement
général sur la protection des données
qui quand même limite enfin voilà
protège les données notamment les
données de santé qui font partie des
données le plus protégées plus sensible
et donc effectivement aux États-Unis
c'est pas le cas là encore tout
récemment le Royaume-Uni apparemment a
d'opté une réglementation aussi beaucoup
plus
libéral que celle du rgpd
après effectivement si on voit les
choses d'un point de vue positif
l'intervention des gafam c'est qu'il y a
des normes moyens financiers donc on
peut imaginer qu'ils vont pouvoir
financer des recherches voilà que les
biologistes vont pouvoir
progresser sur la vie peut-être pas
encore l'immortalité mais en prolongeant
de de en promettant de rallonger la vie
c'est l'engagement vieillir en meilleure
santé c'est surtout bien compris
l'objectif maintenant
cet apport des potentiels des gafams ils
pourraient accélérer les recherches dans
dans vos domaines respectifs des moyens
ça peut toujours accélérer les
recherches je serai un peu méfiant il y
a pas que les Gafa il y a des
investissements massifs privés même pour
certains pays publics dans ces dans ces
dans cette recherche pas en France
dans d'autres pays et
qui part sur cette sur cette idée
que en fait on est très près de pouvoir
appliquer à l'homme donc c'est un peu la
carotte en fait finalement qui est vendu
pour ses alors évidemment les
scientifiques sont ravis parce qu'ils
continuent leurs recherches et j'en
serais j'en suis ravi également mais à
moins j'ai peur il y a aucune
application pour l'instant qui a été
validée chez l'homme de ce concept de
traiter de ralentir les mécanis
biologiques et avec j'ai peur qu'on
arrive à une bulle où il y a une demande
de retour sur investissement qui soit
assez douloureux c'est mon c'est ma
crainte on va dire ça comme votre vie
sur le
pilier des financements supplémentaires
qui viennent du privé pour retravailler
sur le vieillissement je pense que c'est
une bonne chose parce que c'est ça vous
avez d'ailleurs un projet dans ce sens
je crois oui mais
c'est une un institut qui serait un
institut à la fois financé par le public
par le qui soit dédié à justement au
vieillissement en bonne santé à la
longévité et pas et pas s'intéresser
plus que ça aux maladies du
vieillissement puisque
ma conviction c'est qu'il faut traiter
les cellules le vieillissement des
cellules et donc avant que les maladies
n'arrivent donc c'est de la prévention
c'est de la prévention exactement il y a
beaucoup de choses déjà sur la
prévention aussi fait de l'exercice
physique vous vous avez une alimentation
saine déjà on voit bien que et même on
voit que des changements
d'alimentation est mise en place de d'un
exercice physique ça peut faire un petit
peu marche arrière au niveau de nos
horloges biologiques donc typiquement il
y a une possibilité de réversion tout de
même
on va parler de demain maintenant il
nous reste 4 minutes pour le faire c'est
très peu de temps qu'est-ce qui sera
faisable d'un point de vue légal d'un
point de vue éthique aussi bien entendu
demain dans les prochaines lois
bioéthiques par exemple en France est-ce
qu'on a déjà des frontières qui se
dessine pour demain de ce point de vue
là du point de vue juridique éthique
alors législatif
ce qu'on peut constater effectivement
c'est quand même qu'il y a une évolution
vers de plus en plus de possibilités
voilà on ouvre le champ des possibles
quand même au fur et à mesure donc on
peut imaginer que ça va probablement
continuer sur un certain nombre de
thèmes après sans doute qu'il y a quand
même un certain nombre de limites
infranchissables et quand même notamment
la question des modifications
transmissibles aux générations futures
reste malgré tout à mon sens une limite
qui va difficile de dépasser puisque
c'est quand même inscrit dans notre Code
civil alors qu'on pourrait bien sûr
modifier mais c'est quand même un des
grands principes ce principe de non
atteinte à l'intégrité de l'espèce
humaine qui par ailleurs et aussi
reprise dans la convention d’autres 97
qui a un traité international c'est le
seul traité international contraignant
concernant les droits de l'homme en
matière bioéthique il y a quand même été
signé par 29 états du Conseil de
l'Europe et qui reprend la les mêmes
règles donc ça ça semble quand même une
limite qui va probablement tenir un
certain temps voir toujours
du respect de la nature humaine oui
l'intégrité de l'espèce humaine ça
l'idée qu'il y aurait nature humaine
quand même immuable et sacrée qu'il
faudrait préserver est-ce qu'il faut
strictement rester dans ce cadre pour
demain avec un respect intégral de la
nature humaine sans transformation de la
nature humaine pour dire les choses très
simplement moi je dirais encore plus
loin en fait c'est à dire que au-delà de
la nature humaine je dirais
l'écosystème biologique dans lequel
duquel on est issu je crois qu'il y a
c'est quelque chose qui est pas assez
dit c'est à dire qu'en fait il y a une
très grande hétérité du vieillissement
dans la nature entre les espèces dont
l'homme une certaine espérance de vie
sans même
donc on a su améliorer d'ailleurs depuis
deux siècles environ il y a des espèces
qui vivent très très peu de temps il y a
des espèces et ça c'est leur adaptation
l'environnement d'accord ça veut dire
que si l'homme décide de d'augmenter ses
limites biologiques
ont même si on en a la technologie
est-ce qu'on va pas casser finalement
des écosystèmes naturels qui vont
au-delà de la de préserver la nature
humaine et la relation entre j'allais
dire les changements globaux
l'environnement et le vieillissement
humain je pense que c'est une thématique
j'allais dire qui n'est pas assez
réfléchie de manière générale à la fois
d'un point de vue scientifique mais
aussi d'un point de vue éthique ou
législatif vous en arrivez à la même
conclusion et vous risquez d'avoir la le
mot de la fin il nous reste une minute
oui alors ce que ce que disait Eric
c'est qu'effectivement la longévité
enfin l'espérance de vie à naissance
elle a doublé quand même au siècle
dernier donc et ça
on peut dire que peut-être les
chercheurs avancent sur la longévité et
qui vont nous faire gagner des années
oui mais la médecine le fait depuis déjà
des années et ça n'est pas critiqué donc
typiquement je ne pense pas que ces
choses vont s'arrêter parce que la
médecine c'est peut-être un but inOuest
de repousser la mort simplement en
traitant les maladies là aujourd'hui on
va traiter peut-être le vieillissement
de nos cellules et essayer de de faire
que on va on va vieillir probablement en
meilleure santé peut-être plus longtemps
on pourra en arriver à mourir en bonne
santé c'est ce que vous êtes en train de
nous voilà c'est un peu l'enjeu c'est à
dire que rester plus jeune plus
longtemps parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
va éviter le vieillissement et les
maladies du vieillissement et puis
mourir sans maladie du vieillissement et
donc mourir en bonne santé même si c'est
même si c'est c'est un petit peu
ambitieux mais bel et bien mourir au
bout du combat on meurt de maladie
cardiaque ceci au maire des maladies je
crois que c'est ça sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce déb at doc
aujourd'hui après ce documentaire vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
tout simplement sur Twitter merci à
Selma Sally qui comme à l'accoutumée à
préparer cette émission et je vous donne
bien sûr rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]